- [Narrator] Ah, Mother's
Day, the one day a year
where people all of the
world pay tribute to mom,
mama, mum, or ma.
But how did it all begin?
Enter Anna Jarvis, the
founder of Mother's Day
who came to despise her own holiday.
Anna Jarvis really,
really loved her mother.
- [Katharine] Her mother dies in 1905,
and in 1907 she really
starts this campaign
that we need to have a day
in honor of what mothers do.
- [Narrator] That's
Dr. Katharine Antolini,
she's an historian and
wrote a book about Anna.
- [Katharine] She always
identified herself
as Anna Jarvis, the
founder of Mother's Day.
- [Narrator] And in 1914, after six years
and state-by-state campaigning,
Jarvis' dream came true:
President Woodrow Wilson
officially designated
the second Sunday of May as Mother's Day.
Hooray, right?
Jarvis felt Wilson was taking
credit for her efforts,
and he wasn't the only source of her ire.
- [Katharine] Anna had a
really wonderful enemies list.
She was mad at the candy industry,
and she was mad at the floral industry,
and she was mad at all of these charities.
- [Narrator] She also turned
on some of her early allies,
including John Wanamaker,
a business tycoon
who saw a commercial
opportunity in Mother's Day.
He started putting the
holiday on everything,
even dishes at his restaurant.
Jarvis did not approve.
- [Katharine] She ordered
this Mother's Day salad,
and once the salad arrived,
Mrs. Jarvis just dumped it
on the floor and walked out.
That was not was the
day was supposed to be.
- [Narrator] What exactly
was the day supposed to be?
- [Katharine] So, it
really wasn't meant to be,
go out, rush out and
buy all these flowers,
and greeting cards, and candy, and gifts,
it was just go home and spend
the day with your mother.
That's all she wants.
- [Narrator] I wonder
what Anna Jarvis would say
about the way Mother's
Day is celebrated today.
- [Katharine] She would
still be defending it
against commercialization.
We celebrate this holiday in ways that she
doesn't think we should.
- [Narrator] Hear that people?
Don't forget about Anna Jarvis,
the mother of Mother's Day,
and please, send your mom a card.
- [Katharine] For her, a
greeting card would be insincere,
it would be cheap, it would be lazy.
If you can't go home, then, you know,
write a letter to her,
not just send a card.
- [Narrator] Got it, write
your mom a handwritten letter.
She deserves it, don't you think?